jean marc bonjour alors qu'on le disait
100 milliards d'euros sont prévus pour
ce plan de relance est ce que ce sera
suffisant
vous savez quand on écoute les chefs
d'entreprise ou les syndicats ça n'est
jamais suffisant mais assez 100
milliards qui se compose de 40 milliards
pour la réindustrialisation 1,20
milliard pour la transition écologique
20 milliards pour l'emploi 20 milliards
aussi pour la saluer la solidarité
nationale
au total donc 100 milliards qui vont
arriver après les plus de 6 400
milliards qui ont été mobilisés en début
de crise en mars donc l'effort global
pour éviter l'écroulement la suite si
complète du système économique français
a quand même été important il est à la
hauteur d'ailleurs de ce qu'a fait
l'allemagne ou même les états unis
ce qui est compliqué en france et qui
fait débat c'est que nous avons
finalement 2 crise à gérer en même temps
et on nous excite pas ça il ya deux
crises la première crise
c'est évidemment lié au confinement
c'est à dire lié à l'arrêt total de
l'activité économique transports cas de
mobilité donc là il faut faire repartir
les machines et on a bien vu depuis le
mois de juin que ça retard mais ça
repart un peu doucement et puis vous
avez une crise structurelle une crise
structurelle qui était antérieure à la
crise du coronavirus mais que le
confinement finalement a révélé très
fort renault était malade avant
l'arrivée du virus n'a dû son offre
mobile ça mais depuis très longtemps
qu'elle devait muter vers la mobilité
électrique
air france avait aussi qu'il avait des
difficultés et puis vous avez beaucoup
de petites entreprises qui vivait un peu
à l'abri de la concurrence sur leur
petit marché
la crise sanitaire l'arrêt mondial des
transports nous a également montré à
quel point nous étions dépendants des
autres
on a perdu depuis longtemps une
souveraineté industrielle dans un
certain nombre de secteurs clés le
coronavirus nous a dit tout cela mais le
coronavirus ne l'a pas inventé alors
justement est-ce que les 40 milliards
d'euros vont suffire pour
réindustrialiser le pays jean-marc vous
savez très clairement ça dépend de ce
qu'on veut en faire le gouvernement peut
demander la réindustrialisation pour des
produits stratégiques
il l'a déjà fait pour les masquer
pour les médicaments pour les matériels
de santé oui mais le gouvernement ne
peut pas tout faire il peut pas tout
faire nous avons perdu beaucoup de nos
industries sous la pression des
consommateurs qui réclamaient des
baisses de prix c'est pas par hasard si
on a accéléré la mondialisation à cette
vitesse dans le textile dans la
mécanique dans tout ce qui est plastique
moulé électroménager le consommateur de
le client y trouvait son compte
la délocalisation des industries s'est
développé vous recherchez des conditions
de prix très avantageuses on s'est mis à
fabriquer en turquie puis en chine puis
en inde des t-shirts des chemises
pourquoi parce que c'était moins cher je
prends pas qu'on puisse rapatrier des
fabrications en europe
toutes ces fabrications en revanche je
pense que les chefs d'entreprise vont
avoir intérêt à éviter de se faire
piéger par un seul fournisseur comme ils
l'ont été au début de l'année notamment
par exemple les constructeurs
automobiles notamment dans
l'électronique
alors 40 milliards c'est beaucoup et
c'est pas beaucoup faut rappeler quand
même que les entreprises ont d'autres
choses de financement les banques les
actionnaires les profits qu'elles
réalisent mais pour activer tous ses
moyens il faut promettre et garantir des
rentabilités et pour que la rentabilité
existe eh bien il faut que les
consommateurs
seul à bord et pourquoi jean marc le
gouvernement at-il retarder l'annoncé de
son plan de relance
alors ça c'est encore une question que
tout le monde se pose notamment les
chefs d'entreprise qui je le rappelle
pour pour leur rentrée cette semaine à
l'université d'été du medef et qui
pensait bien avoir la primeur de ce plan
de relance
je crois que le gouvernement a fait pour
des raisons de calendrier politique et
de communication il faut d'abord régler
on a bien vu la question de la rentrée
scolaire est assez compliqué il faut
ensuite être sûr que les mesures de
protection renforcée contre le virus
seront à accepter par les personnels
d'entreprises qu'on voit ce qui s'est
passé hier
c'est pas évident le masque dans
l'entreprise il est mal supporté et l'aï
d'ailleurs mal supporté par tout le
monde au fonds le gouvernement reste
très hésitant parce que les informations
qu'on a sur l'épidémie sont encore très
floues très anxiogène
on ne sait pas vie n'a évidemment si bas
se passer alors la peur est très
présente c'est une épée de damoclès la
peur est plus dangereuse que le virus
lui même aujourd'hui donc
gouvernement cherche l'un formule qui
pourrait rassurer
pour l'instant il n'a pas encore trouvé
merci beaucoup jean-marc pour votre
décryptage jean marc sylvestre
chroniqueur économique pour rt france